i've had counselling and i think it's
brilliant it's
really really brilliant the recruitment
mentors podcast is proudly sponsored
by vincerie who are weaponizing
recruiters
through tech and the award-winning sauce
breaker who are transforming
the way recruiters work there's an idea
that there you've got five fibers of
resilience mental
emotional physical social and spiritual
the idea is the stronger those five
fibers of resilience
the more resilient you become and the
more resilient you are i think
you know that goes hand in hand with
mental health one thing that we
encourage
at realm is self-development we've got
loads of things in place that do that
but i try to live and breathe that
myself
so try to do a lot to kind of develop
myself in that sense
emotional resilience i think that's
around
stretching yourself so at realm we talk
not so much about getting outside of
your comfort zone but growing your
comfort zone
so doing something that develops you
personally
um physical resilience well that's
that's the easy one to understand
but maybe more difficult one to stick to
but you know
exercise um social resilience i think
that's about
sharing sharing positivity in love with
others looking after others i think
that's very rewarding
uh and i think the strongest one of all
is the spiritual one and by spiritual i
don't necessarily mean
religion or or some sort of you know
voodoo or witchcraft but rather a sense
of purpose a goal something that drives
you
um and again i'm gonna refer to the talk
that i went to the back end of last year
that really
helped crystallize all of this for me
one practical tip that i got given then
was to have have goals that stretch you
goals that are not
so obviously attainable that you know
you know you're gonna do that thing
but things that are maybe a little bit
dicey like it's push and go
if not slightly unrealistic write them
down
and stick them in front of you right and
and the idea is that if they're in front
of you all the time you're
unconscious without you knowing it he's
taking that information
in and he's processing it and he's
getting creative and trying to do
something with it
but also if you're having a crap day you
can just look down at it
and remind yourself this is this is why
i'm doing this